>> Geraldo: YOUR TIE GOES.
>> Jesse: A BIG DAY FOR
DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE RAVED ABOUT
HOW GREAT SANCTUARY CITIES ARE
FOR YEARS.
>> SANCTUARY POLICIES MAKE
CITIES SAFER.
>> TO BE CLEAR ABOUT WHAT
CHICAGO IS, IT ALWAYS WILL BE A
SANCTUARY CITY.
>> LET'S BUILD A HOUSE STRONG TO
THE ONCOMING STORMS THAT
PROVIDES SHELTER TO ALL WHO NEED
IT AND SANCTUARY TO ALL WHO SEEK
IT.
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
READY TO GIVE THESE LIBERALS
EXACTLY WHAT THEY WANTED BY SAY
HE MAY DUMP ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS
IN THEIR CITIES.
>> WE COULD FIX THAT SO FAST IF
THE DEMOCRATS WOULD AGREE BUT IF
WE DON'T AGREE WE MIGHT AS WELL
DO WHAT THEY SAY THEY THEY WANT.
WE'LL BRING THEM TO
SANCTUARY-CITY AREAS AND LET
THAT PARTICULAR AREA TAKE CARE
OF IT WHETHER IT'S A STATE OR
CITY, CALIFORNIA IS SAYING WE
WANT MORE PEOPLE AND THEY WANT
MORE PEOPLE IN THEIR SAFRPTHUARY
CITIES.
WE'LL GIVE -- IN THEIR SANCTUARY
WE CAN GIVE THEM AN UNLIMITED
SUPPLY.
LET'S SEE IF THEY'RE HAPPY.
>> Jesse: NANCY PELOSI'S HOME
DISTRICT IN SAN FRANCISCO IS ONE
OF THE AREAS THE WHITE HOUSE
DISCUSSED BUT FOR SOME REASON
THE HOUSE SPEAKER IS UPSET ABOUT
IT.
>> I DON'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
IT BUT AGAIN, IT'S JUST ANOTHER
NOTION THAT IS UNWORTHY OF THE
PRESIDENCY OF THE UNITED STATES
AND DISRESPECTFUL TO CHALLENGES
THAT WE FACE AS A COUNTRY, AS A
PEOPLE, TO ADDRESS WHO WE ARE, A
NATION OF IMMIGRANTS.
>> Jesse: GERALDO, I DON'T KNOW
IF THIS IDEA IS GOING TO HAPPEN
BUT IT DOES SERVE THE PURPOSE OF
ILLUSTRATING THE HYPOCRISY OF
SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO SAY, YES, BRING THEM
IN, PROVIDE SANCTUARY BUT NOT IN
MY CITY.
>> Geraldo: I THAT WHAT THE
PRESIDENT IS SAYING IS BORN OF
FRUSTRATION BY LACK OF
COOPERATION OF THE DEMOCRATS ON
THE BORDER.
THEY ARE DOING NOTHING TO HELP
OTHER THAN MAKING THINGS MORE
DIFFICULT BUT THIS IS A STUNT.
THIS IS ALSO ILLEGAL.
I'M TELLING YOU.
IT'S ILLEGAL.
ASK EMILY.
YOU CANNOT USE PEOPLE AS PROPS
TO MAKE A POLITICAL POINT.
>> Greg: THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE
BEEN DOING FOR 40 YEARS.
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS.
>> Geraldo: THE ROAD FROM THE
BORDER TO WHEREVER THE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS ARE TAKEN WILL BE
LINED WITH LAWSUITS.
I GUARANTEE YOU.
>> Jesse: EMILY, I THINK THE
RESTRICTION IS FINANCIAL.
IT COSTS MONEY TO TRANSPORT
PEOPLE ALL THE WAY FROM THE
BORDER TO SAN FRANCISCO.
>> Emily: ONE OF THE LIMITATIONS
ON IT WOULD BE BUDGETARY IN
TERMS OF WHETHER IT'S CONSIDERED
LEGAL.
I WANT TO POINT OUT THAT I THINK
THE BIGGEST ISSUE TO ME IS THAT
THE DEMOCRATS AREN'T LISTENING
TO LOCAL LAW ENFORCEMENT AND
THEY ARE NOT LISTENING TO
REGULAR PEOPLE.
IT'S SUCH A TOP-DOWN DISCUSSION.
THAT'S WHY THERE IS SUCH
FRICTION AT THE LOCAL COMMUNITY
LEVEL THAT PEOPLE ARE UPSET
ABOUT.
THE WOMAN WAS MURDERED BY A SIX
TIME DETAINER REQUEST ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANT WITH A HISTORY OF
VIOLENT FELONIES, A TOKEN CASE
OF WHICH UNFORTUNATELY THERE ARE
A LOT.
POINT.
GUESS WHAT HAPPENED ON TUESDAY.
THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
ADMINISTRATION VOTED
OVERWHELMINGLY TO SOFTEN THE
SAFRPTHUARY POLICY -- TO SOFTEN
THE SANCTUARY POLICY.
IT DOESN'T PROVIDE THE CLARITY
THEY CAN USE TO UNDERSTAND HOW
AND WHEN THEY CAN IMMIGRATE
LEGALLY SO IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
THEY'RE VOTING TO SOFTEN IT AND
THE IMMIGRATION LAWS ARE
DYSFUNCTIONAL, EVERYONE IS
CONFUSED AND WHOSE JOB IS IT
THEN TO CLARIFY?
GET TO IT, LEGISLATORS.
INSTEAD OF SQUAWKING ABOUT IT,
DO YOUR JOB AND CLARIFY THE
POLICY AND THEN WE CAN ALL
SURVIVE.
>> Jesse: GREG.
>> Greg: THIS HEADLINE FROM "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
WHITE HOUSE WANTED BORDER
DETAINEES RELEASED IN SANCTUARY
CITIES TO TARGET TRUMP FOES.
EVEN THE MEDIA IS PORTRAYING THE
VERY POLICIES THAT THEY CLAIM TO
LOVE AS PUNISHMENT.
THEY'RE MAD AT TRUMP FOR GIVING
THEM WHAT THEY ASKED FOR.
LET'S SAY IT'S A STUNT.
LET'S SAY IT'S A BAD IDEA.
THE FACT IS IF YOU DON'T LIKE
HAVING THESE RELEASED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS THERE YOU HAVE TO
EXPLAIN WHY BECAUSE THIS IS YOUR
POLICY.
YOU HAVE CREATED THIS PROBLEM.
IF PELOSI THINKS IT'S A STUNT --
DON'T SAY IT'S ILLEGAL, SAY WHY
DON'T YOU WANT THEM THERE?
>> Jesse: THAT'S THE GREAT
THING.
IF YOU'RE A REPORTER IN
WASHINGTON, PELOSI GIVES HER
THURSDAY PRESS CONFERENCE.
WHY DON'T THEY ASK NANCY PELOSI
THAT?
>> Dana: IT'S GOING TO BE A
DOOZY NEXT WEEK.
SHE'S GOING TO HAVE A LOT TO
ANSWER.
I DON'T BELIEVE THIS POLICY IS A
STUNT -- LET'S SAY IT'S
IMPLEMENTED.
I DON'T THINK IT STOPS THE FLOW
OF MIGRANTS COMING TO THE BORD.
WE GET TO GO TO SAN FRANCISCO?
SANTA BARBARA?
>> Greg: IT'S STILL BERSERK.
THEY SHOULD EMBRACE IT.
>> Emily: IT DOESN'T ADDRESS THE
REAL PROBLEMS.
THE PROBLEM IS THE MIGRANT
CRISIS AT THE BORDER.
>> Dana: WE'RE BEING
OVERWHELMED.
WE DON'T HAVE ENOUGH RESOURCES.
IT REMINDS ME OF BRIDGE-GATE,
USING POLITICAL LEVERS IN ORDER
TO ATTACK YOUR POLITICAL ENEMIES
AND I DON'T THINK THAT THE
PRESIDENT'S BASE NEEDS FIRING
UP.
I GET THAT IT'S A GREAT POINT
LIKE IT PLAYS MIND GAMES WITH
THE DEMOCRATS.
THEN WHAT ABOUT YOU?
WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO DO?
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
IF THE ADMINISTRATION WHO DENIED
THIS UP UNTIL TWO HOURS BEFORE
THE PRESIDENT TWEETED IT AND
SAID IT WAS GOING TO HAPPEN,
DON'T BRAINSTORM IN EMAILS.
BRAINSTORM IN PFRNLT NOT IN
EMAILS.
>> Greg: I THINK IT WAS PROBABLY
AN IDEA THAT THEY PUT FORTH BUT
I DO THINK IT DOES MAKE PROGRESS
BECAUSE YOU ARE GOING TO FORCE
THE DEMOCRATS TO EITHER EMBRACE
OR DEVIATE FROM A POLICY THAT
THEY BELIEVE HYPOTHETICALLY.
MAKE IT REALITY.
>> Geraldo: WHY NOT GET THE
DEMOCRATS TO COOPERATE WITH YOU?
LET THE PRESIDENT CALL -- I LOVE
THE PRESIDENT BUT HE'S
TEMPESTUOUS AND THEN SKINNED.
HE SHOULD CALL UP CHUCK SCHUMER.
CALL HIM UP AND SAY, "LISTEN
BEING DUDE.
LET'S DO SOMETHING BEFORE WE'RE
REALLY IN THE HEAT OF THE
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
WE'VE GOT A MILLION PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE SOUTHERN
BORDER.
THERE IS THE CRISIS OF WHICH YOU
SPOKE."
>> Greg: WE HAVE TWO PARTIES WHO
NEVER SOLVED THE PROBLEM BECAUSE
THEY NEVER WANTED TO.
>> Geraldo: AGREED.
>> Greg: TRUMP BEING ESSENTIALLY
APOLITICAL, HE WAS A DEMOCRAT
FOR A LONG TIME, HE'S A
REPUBLICAN BECAUSE IT MAKES
SENSE.
HE IS THE FIRST PERSON REALLY TO
SAY LET'S TRY TO SOLVE IT FOR
GOOD.
HE'S BEING THE ADULT IN THE
ROOM.
>> Dana: I THINK THERE ARE
DEFINITELY -- I WORKED FOR
GEORGE W. BUSH.
HE WANTED TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
THERE WAS A DEAL ON THE TABLE
THAT'S PROBABLY THE ONE THAT'S
GOING TO BE SOLIDIFIED.
THE PEOPLE ON THE EXTREMES,
RIGHT AND LEFT, ARE THE ONES
THAT DON'T WANT THE DEAL AND
THAT'S WHAT PULLS PEOPLE APART.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP COULD
MAKE THIS DEAL TOMORROW.